so you've never acted before Godfather I
so who's playing call they said number
had some playing caller
I told Sinatra that story at the Copa I
told the stripper II started crying I
mean how ironic is that
Sinatra was my only singing teacher the
bigger the pain the bigger the upset you
could have gone either way by the way
you have an aspect of your life that is
linked to the mob and then the other
side is entertainment
you've met every single mob boss in the
US right all of them every mob field I
met every guy and I was always the kid
well you never actually and joined them
up there's a lot of stories about me of
people I killed it all that I'm with
Marlon Brando he says to me too bad you
were never a Marilyn Monroe Joe Kennedy
I'm gonna set up my own Monroe with
Bobby and John and they were gonna film
it like they did with Jay Hoover before
I tell you what I'm sitting down with
you today I just kind of want to tell
you what Robert De Niro said about him
okay so this is the book called
Hollywood Godfather Robert De Niro says
Johnny Russell walks the walk talks to
talk what a life
a worthy read right now before we even
start the interview let me kind of give
you a glimpse about what stories you may
hear about today Marlon Brando Marilyn
Monroe James Caan Al Pacino De Niro
there's a lot of stories the people this
guy part he had one of the best clubs in
Vegas for seven years that everybody
would go to party I don't want to spoil
all these stories I want him to tell the
stories to you but today's guest with me
the one and only from the movie
Godfather Gianni Russo here with us
Johnny thank you man willing to have
y'all all was my pleasure you know I'm
sitting here watch and get ready to do
this yeah obviously together and I'm
telling myself what you and I just
talked about in the last hour
fascinating thank you the amount of
stuff you've experienced it's crazy like
a hundred people's lives into one life
well I had a I started very young it's
12 got the loyalty of so many people and
I'm still around 76 oh look how many
years I've been doing it that's
unbelievable and but I did interesting
things I was not a person that I'd get
bored if I wasn't changing my occupé
every seven years in doing something
like that so I say you know I'm trying
to say what angles to go but I said we
start off with Godfather how about we do
that we do get I want to go Godfather
and then we go back to upbringing story
how that was and then how it led to post
Godfather but I want to start off with
Godfather so I've heard a lot of stories
okay about how it happened where you got
the role right cop you know they're
looking for different people to play
Carlos and Carlo and they're thinking
about who this guy is gonna be and it's
somehow someway you come out of nowhere
and you start playing at the roles so
what is your version of the story based
on whatever I won't hear from you well
that's probably the cleanest version
because what I've heard it's craziness
no I I always on my ego I saw the
tremendous ego and I had to drive and I
always want to be an actor and I always
heard you know your trials and
tribulations you got a sputter you got
to do this and I figured how am I gonna
get in then they came out with the book
mm-hmm and I had someone read it to me
because I can't read at that time she
read it and then they knew they were
having problems with anti-defamation
league the Colombo family so I at the
time was I jewelry stores in Las Vegas
and I was doing you know all kinds of
things down there so I had I always do
my own commercials so I have the camera
crew so I shot a scene for Michael scene
for Carlo and the scene for Sonny you
did all those three I did the three got
it and then I played politics and I got
to meet Betty makar kind who was Al Rudd
ease executive secretary
so how girlfriend got to me to her I
said I had this test and I was Freeman
everybody in the world must be sending
tests how can I make this exclusive so I
said what kind of causes like she's all
he loves Bentley's and Rose Royce's I
just happened to have one eye - what
kind of women she was Chinese women who
this is who this is Betty McCord
al ruddy secretary and you're asking who
and how what what would attract him got
it so so I got my 16 millimeter
real a film that I shot
and I got the book cover and I wrapped
it and I got my Chinese chick I had a
find one it was easy in Vegas I went to
the Tropicana Hotel and the line had
every girl in the world I found this
little Chinese girl I paid her a
thousand Thomas which is a lot of money
but I had so much cash I'd say that get
rid of cash at that time I said three
days drive-in rest I bought her a wet
look this material looked like leather
but it wasn't made her little uniform to
match my car and that I had Betty macaw
it arranged communicator drive on I
didn't want to left at the gate I said I
want to drive on for her to come here
Sal arranged it so we had it all planned
so and I made her give me blow by blow
by blow I was down the street and so she
pulls onto the lot and when she pulls up
to rut his building he was looking at he
said why cuz they already told him this
car is great to see this chick come to
your office he there's no clue no he
didn't even know he had she's delivering
and then she delivers this to him they
talked for a brief minute and it leaves
unbeknownst to me my test was shot on
Aerith Lex film 16 millimeter camera
with a mag stripe that's before tape
before all that and I bought old film so
it had a sepia look the color was
destroyed but unbeknownst to me Francis
Ford Coppola was trying to convince
Panama to shoot the whole movie in the
sepia look antique look so wasn't like
test that they liked they were sending
it all around to see that's what it
should be so now they send me a letter
because I read in the newspaper that
they were going to use unknowns like so
many people said they were gonna hunt
this guy to the end and it was all false
and they sent me a nice letter saying
we're sorry we misled you obviously you
went to a lot of expense to make your
test whether using actors I saw so now I
knew that Columbo was using this book as
as the footstone to peel everything
about Italian Americans how they've
shown in this con
he's gonna ban this movie got it and he
had a big rally I mean thousands and
thousands of people showed up at
Columbus Circle to pick it and he was
picking the FBI boat and they called him
in can't being on the sentence
understand one thing you're a head of a
family you don't pick the P up for you I
tell them they say you better stop with
all this [ __ ] like so many other
Dawn's as we go through life as I did
got out of water so I somehow or other
said how am I gonna get their attention
and I didn't have to do it at that I I
was a planning to do something some
idiots on the west coast Italian
Americans we're gonna show Joe their
support they blew up the gates of
Melrose a paramount they're 20 feet off
they blew it up boom up on Sunday
morning they were laying on the streets
so this is my opportunity so I called
Benny Makar I said Benny what's
happening she's all over the know she's
yeah ice is a whiz ruddy or he's never
leavin to go to New York Bobby Evans
Stanley Jaffe and they all flew to New
York
they said that we gotta stop this they
took these people gotta kill him it was
an idiot that did that so I took the
advantage I got on a red-eye I flew
there and at the Gulf and Western
building which is Trump now I'm there
sitting there and the only reason they
knew me they all saw my test so I'm
sitting in the bench of the lobby and
Ronnie looks to me says Jenny ruse us
yeah so what are you doing I said we've
got a problem I think I could straighten
it who would have no problem
iStopMotion me on you got a problem so
he went upstairs I don't know if he was
going up to call the FBI called New York
I didn't know what he was gonna do they
come down about half hour late and I go
up everybody's in the room and they said
what do you know about what's going on
here
I smell the world knows what's going on
it Italians are not gonna make me make
this movie unless you do the right thing
and what's that ice well I know and I
didn't know I was [ __ ] I know what's
bothering them and I think if we
straighten that out they'll let you make
the movie if without them you're not
gonna get the union cooperation not
getting any locations and this was
already when Francis was doing tests
they had a cinema will heal and they
would have a Mulberry Street they went
it to lunch they stole the truck it was
like 2,000
I was right the chemical they just took
it while to let them know you don't come
to our neighbor without permission so
they really knew this is not just
[ __ ] and by the bunch of button but
the budget by the way was well like a
five million dollars he asked for and he
wanted eighty three days they give him
like 50 something days no what's crazy
how you gonna get that done well we did
it well then they started when they
started seeing the dailies when we're
getting ahead of ourselves so what
happened so I now go down the street
because the league had an office on
Madison Avenue and this young attorney
who stole my attorney bearish logic he
was easier local yeah absolutely I've
got a great guy and he under yourself he
was really well-known mob attorney as he
grew but there's a young kid at the time
so I go to the league and that Joe
didn't come in yet so I go to Brooklyn
see Joe I said Joe cuz it was selling a
buck above that's how they were raising
money Italian flagging him a buck so I
see - I see Joe this movie Keuka make a
lot of money it sounds I gotta make
money with this I said if you sit with
them I could arrange a meeting
bring Barry with us let him read the
book whatever you don't like let him
straighten it out
so how do I make money I saw I'm gonna
arrange a 90's paramount like this I
said I'm gonna arrange me to get the
world premiere in every major city the
night before it opens as you could sell
tickets $400 on a $50 you could arrange
for that I said I didn't know if I could
uh so now I go back decide set up the
meeting
that's what's good for you let's do 10
o'clock tomorrow that's okay so I go up
there I know they all know the book they
won't come together and I said I
arranged a sit-down for you they said
what I says you never sit down do we
leave anyway so no they could come here
tomorrow
ten o'clock in the morning so I told
Joyce and bring people will say broke
mine arrested Chico when he brought a
crew it was like the original cast for
the cut they committed so now I just
spoke to Joe I'm down the lobby I'm
gonna bring him up there third third
floor I should do one thing we get this
on I play Michael and Sonya call
no problem so we go out they talk back
and forth this time the other and they
brought off certain points that then
they like being referred to as guineas
and Robson this they don't want to be
used they go they don't want those were
there anyone of that gonna be used
anyways in the script Oreo is old it was
supposed to and then one guy was so
funny though interesting she's funny
with good job bad boy I have to being
that you brought it up I was the only
one that used clean it up you Guinea
brat that I shot that scene awake after
Colombo got shot cuz come on Mike I said
clean it up gotta say what I said she
was a Kenny Brad that's what we used to
say in the neighborhood you know it's
like black people call themselves
whatever they call themselves
we called ourselves Guinea he didn't
want it in the book so I used to ride
away everybody went crazy
I said don't worry buddy you just got
shot he ain't gonna say nothing so now
we have this meeting and they resolve it
they said we're gonna read it we'll take
out what you want they shake hands and
that's together the hammer everything's
happening he's gonna get the world for
me is so they will stay getting up I'd
say go Joe what about me you look around
he goes like this
everybody said like he was God everybody
sat down is what are we gonna do for my
boy here they saw we're gonna give a
part I said no no no no I said you do I
play Michael's son your call so they
said well this is a news to a lot of
people in your audience they said we
already cast Sonny its carmine Caridi
he's a Broadway play man for my mantra
big guy and James Caan is playing
Michael I so who's playing call they
said number had some playing caller they
looked at each other and Joe says he's
playing Carlo and that was it so then
they played another game on me it's have
your agent call ice I got no agent you
don't have an agent no he says are you
in the Union us you know i so don't
worry about i did my homework
this is a tap hot least a right-to-work
state you give me the letter
I'll go joining you you know they gave
me let Iran over I play caller you
changed my life
Wow 50 years I mean not all partners
with vikon that's crazy so that's pretty
well to think about that so you've never
acted before Godfather
never done a movie by I'm a born actor
but I never but but but I'm talking like
oh you should know nothing nothing so
you closed and sold yourself into it
yeah now let me ask you let's go prior
to that cuz now I wanted to go to this
part how you got it and then we're gonna
get tuna Marlon Marlon Brando this
stories
let's go prior to this so who were you
in high school you and I are in high
school I know where the high school you
didn't want to high school when I got
out of Bellevue I hit the streets I was
a [ __ ] yet see what they did was I had
an incident I don't forget it to that
now I had an incident in the hospital
then they moved me from the polio ward
let's talk about that listen the insane
war I went upstairs for 72 hours
observation but talk about that talked
about the fact on you know you're seven
years old what happened there just prior
to me going to Bellevue and being
quarantined my mom I got up like my
father's old school time so I had two
older sisters we're living in a
two-bedroom flat down on Mulberry Street
so my sisters had a room my mother
father had that room so where they're
gonna put me is they had a utility
closet which they cleaned out they put a
youth mattress on the floor and why I
think I get away with a lot of things we
had a five-gallon kerosene thing that
they used to put to fuel the heat in the
house and every five minutes a boom in
the stench of kerosene I think I'm brain
damaged so today I'm gonna use that
sometime in a case so I was there and
the only way to get out of that bed was
on the left side so one morning I got up
I couldn't get out I had no feeling I'm
all of a sudden what how are you at the
tenants I was just seven seven and you
know nothing so I call my mother and
remind my father was still home yet he
started all while giving some ask me to
be alright
you know maybe he's got a cramp you know
so my father being the mother as she was
at the time took me to a clinic down the
block named you know I don't know what
they're talking about you know like I
hear that kid at that year when paying
attention to that then the next morning
the bell rings early and I hear my
mother crying and I thought my mother
and father had another fight they were
always fighting and - ambulance guys are
there and they came for me because they
did the blood war
command polio and everybody was so
frightened but polio in America at that
time this late-teen 49 people were dying
thousands of people they thought it was
the war and they showed up mobile
fountains they fire hydrants everything
no swimming pools because they didn't
know how to control was that contagious
Wow
and then I was a part of Jonas Salk's
vaccine experiments and that was the
screw-up at first too and I was already
going to church everyday with my
grandmother so and I'm saying to garden
why didn't you do this to me God I mean
I I mean I can cry about it now girls
they took me I had it here I couldn't
believe it man and you're seven years
old
and they brought a small stretch
upstairs because we were a little
tenement and they could be one stretch
thank God so the guy put his arms
underneath my arms and that might try to
hold my mother's hand they carry me down
these steps they put me ambulance
so now I go to the hospital and I'm
begging my mother if she had assigned me
in please don't leave me so I'm not
gonna leave you I didn't want to say the
nurses with callous or not sense it but
that's what they do they weren't worried
about me and I'm praying saying it
they've say that my patron saint hmm and
after about a half hour paperwork we
went upstairs and I remember I was on
the gurney they slapped me in my mother
took all my clothes they put me in a
gown and then my mother's holding my
hand and the nurse said you have to let
his hand go I said what do you mean no
your mother can't go here and I looked
up and I saw the biggest word in my life
quarantined across the door you remember
that vividly oh yeah
I didn't know what it said but I saw
there's not like Exeter's like stop
quarantine unit that was it I went in
there for five years five years did you
see how I okay my mom and dad never what
do you mean never every dollar to visit
five years I guess would you see for
five years nobody
I saw twenty kids in the ward you son
nobody for five years nobody
no family no family first of all I think
it got to be that my father want to come
anyway because you know he's that kind
of guy but my mother but I I saw even
the other kids never had business but
for the first three or four
and that was in August and my birthday's
in December but I'm about to tell you is
probably one of the reasons I'm alive
today there's two reasons one was
Dolores blown
she was the candy striper when she got
there she was calling Gambino's nice and
he told her there's a kid from the
neighborhood make sure you're watching
they will always watch me I didn't know
it because of you know our relationship
in Sicily and all that your uncle was a
Khmer - who - yeah now with the game
being us from connected to that ya know
they the other way are they all the way
around they sent those guys here because
the real real power is in Sicily so
listen yeah still live yeah love it so
what happened was she would bring me the
jello and you the you know hug at night
but now my birthday was coming to send
the 12th I think maybe they'll surprise
me they'll come nobody came I was
hysterical I meant you know seven years
old
just turning eight that December and I
heard on the radio this consent very
absorbent that's how my life's cycles go
I heard on the radio WN e w said today
is Frank Sinatra's birthday chairman of
the board
Hoboken italian-american and little
skinny kid I was skinny and I related to
this guy
I told Sinatra that story at the Copa
four or five years later I was 16 so
maybe a little more than that I told the
story started crying I saw so not to cry
twice in his life personally that day
and I was backstage between shows at
Caesar's Palace when his mother's plane
was his plane but it was missing that
she was supposed to be the second show
the tables chairs were there and he's
not a religious guy and at the end of
the first show he said I'd like you all
if you would please whatever your
religious beliefs are pray for my mother
she's supposed to be sitting here
worried because they didn't want to tell
him the plane had a mountain which is
ironic because when he abused the Martin
later on Deans son hit the same mountain
get out of here same mountain ken how
did you know that weird Wow I was like
but and I became close to Frank with
that you know because of that phone for
seven for seven to twelve you don't see
your parents five years they rain that's
that's an eternity that's an eternity
I don't watch how do you do day to do
anything anybody else did if you were to
get out what happens though when I got
out I went back to the neighborhood the
only thing I knew you know then the
parallels even went round we'll get into
it later that's how her and I connected
she was in an orphanage in in the valley
yeah looking at water brother studio and
she said something gonna be as an
actress and I when I finally got the bed
the window with the bed like maybe took
two years to get to that window and I
finally saw what uptown was I'm 133 but
I'm still looking up I only saw a little
Italy the neighborhood is crazy and that
was my goal I'm gonna be up here I'm
gonna do what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be
Sinatra
now I had Sinatra I mean how ironic is
that Sinatra was my only singing teacher
and he wind up baptized by less on the
channel crazy and you end up singing
yourself you become a singer yourself
you perform for a bunch of events oh my
god you won awards of who you you know
what Awards the gym you weren't like a
six you said six oh why not not be
singing though I was producing no
producing yeah but you've been singing a
trumpet would put parties here you would
ask what's wrong little finger on e for
me yeah I mean yeah I opened Trump
marina but let's go back to twelve so
did you see your parents post twelve did
you go back and live with your parents
don't know no I used to go visit them I
didn't I knew I couldn't be there my
father was always abusive I mean there
was times my father I could my father
has a young kid yeah if I went to a
school told me and you see me on the
street if I don't acknowledge
don't say Wow cuz he was a player you
want to be pick up girls you know why
nobody you know he had three kids he was
real bull
a red shirt until he died that's who he
was and he always abused my mother and
but you know I to me I was I wasn't
bitter at them I was sad that they
didn't have the courage I mean you try
to take one of my kids I got a lot of
kids I got 11 kids take one of my kids
I'll grab that kid go to Canada you know
like so many people didn't during the
draft you don't take a kid and it's
opening or go look what I am tonight
thank God
yeah no doubt about it sometimes you you
hear these that yeah that's what I think
I think there's a big part of it where
the bigger the pain
the bigger the upset you could have gone
either way by the way it was dead yeah I
was younger I want to become an assassin
I was so bitter so but but that's the
part because you have it you have an
aspect of your life that is linked to
the mob a big part of it life that's
linked to the mob and then the other
side is entertainment right I go to
Delancey Street one day and I see this
new invention called ballpoint pens
you don't need ink anymore hmm and the
stores ten feet one so I go in the store
and there's the main there and I should
you the owner Stice yeah and they
introduce myself
and he said I'm Mr Rabinowitz I said Mr
Rabinowitz I got I got something I think
he's gonna love it I said what's that he
says I'm gonna become your partner and
he looked at me and he calls his brother
Leo
Kabhi I want you to meet our new partner
he's playing with with a heavy Jewish
accident and I said I'm serious and so
are you gonna be my partner tell me tell
me
I said you're selling ballpoint pens
yeah I said well I'm gonna experience
your business it's how you're gonna do
that
I see you're here you got ten feet 200
feet wide I said you should be selling
spaghetti not ballpoint pens so he said
very funny how you gonna do this I said
you're gonna give me 50 pen if I give
nobody nothing dude are you giving I
said listen to me please I'll take take
you ain't taking that's all right I'll
leave here with 50 pence tomorrow and
you come if 20 a missile I pay for them
give me the 50 again I'll do that every
day is how do I know you come back I
said my grandfather told me
look me in the eye give me a word and
shake his hand that's it that's all you
need in life he's a grandfather smile
man
he gave me depends then I asked because
I've seen one I didn't have went to
office space them and I saw they got
paid paychecks I walked to the bank and
they filling up my lungs come on man
Pinto was full on a board I knew he was
a marine Midland Bank so I go in I said
when does the paydays here you saw we
have to stagger them cuz a pain in cash
I said would you give me the list of
when you're paying who is why you wanna
rob my Snow White's that I have an idea
cuz I wanted to go but you got your
humble up let me show up 15 minutes
later hmm you had all this time means
yeah so it got to be much would buy that
I'd walk into this place I knew this
schedule every day I was somewhere else
but then it got to be they just open the
drawer they had typewriter a small port
been said okay don't want no more so I
came out I was disappointed and it did
you know all the train stations are
still the same some on Broadway and
canal and ICN and awe and says uptown I
always wonder go uptown from the
hospital I'll go it up so I got off of
59th Street and Fifth Avenue and I made
that my stop I stood outside and Sharon
Ellen and self-doubt van cleef and arpel
i have this [ __ ] um i was starting to
pull it into my truck because it was
growing too fast
my little cigar box but I didn't take
the typewriter braces just these little
drew pencil ever coming out everybody
would come by give me a dollar you know
and I saw to me as a kid I you look at
everybody I said everything is Sunday
here cuz I used to talk to the doorman
is what do you mean as everybody has
this Sunday best on because they all
dressed to the nines my neighbor nobody
interested maybe Sunday to go to church
that's how I met Costello
you started walking down used to cost
town every day he lived on the west side
that's how you go connect and he walk
down 59th Street come to Fifth Avenue go
into the sherry Netherlands go showing
come back out that's how I got to see
him and then you touch my shoulder this
is kid what are you doing here
I said I'm selling bends you looked at
bend over the cigar box
you throw a dollar in $5
take a bath this one on for a couple of
months there one day maybe had more time
you always had somebody or two guys will
and he says to me what's your name I
told my name
he says you're Italian as hell his ruse
always yeah this is who's Angelo Russo
to you was Angela listen my uncle he's
Angela no she's your uncle
I said yeah why his when's the last time
you saw I say never so I said there hung
him in London for in 1948 and he looked
at Blackie not renewing the guy's a name
now he says this guy's telling truth I
said on why I said I take offense to
that and he looked at me he says you
know whether the world of klunkins
everybody knows where there's in the
lobby in a walled-off I'm [ __ ] you
he's bday tomorrow at 11 o'clock it's
okay and he said Blackie take that cigar
box home you never do this again I don't
want to see you banging on the street
gave me two $100 bills I was with that
rental 1873 till he died and I couldn't
go to the scheudle because they had a
warrant out for my arrest so I went to
the school across the street he was it
was buried up on 86th feet and park
every Campbell's the big everybody gets
buried out of there but I had to show my
respect then I called his wife that
night
and I described what she said where why
you and then she said I shouldn't even
ask you that cuz she knew they were
looking for me I said I just want to let
you know you look gorgeous
today my respects I've been praying for
him and I was in that's how long I was
with this guy would you learn and that
and that appear oh my god I mean you you
you've met every single mob boss in the
US right all of them well not only that
at the time unbeknownst to me I was a
kid I was just a messenger and you know
he'd give me Alma Lopes go here go there
first I was in stayed in the city for
about two or three years I used to go to
the support minute this do is 24 phone
writers here blackboards data counting
room here and then I picked up here at
the end of the day that I make all my
stops sherry Netherlands Hotel the Plaza
Hotel all the hotels all the barber
shops is where they took the numbers and
the boss bets I would take them and not
taking to the Wyndham Hotel on 58th
Street and every day I'd go to insert
the elevator top floor go there and they
had people out there and I'd go in I
mean it was like a bank everybody
advises was count
who's doing this so I thought I was
being cute then I he'd go to dinner
every night
mm-hmm and if he needed me this before
cellphones they know how to get in touch
with me and I'd come back and I did
errands for him at night he went to
dinner every night Oh mr. Costello this
guy thank God it was him and not some
crazy like the John Gotti or somebody
this guy was a gentleman of a gentleman
here we never know he was in the moment
that's why when Vito Genovese came out
and he wanted his family back Frank
couldn't be happier to give it to him
because Meyer Lansky and the ALF in
Chicago all over the world put to sin to
get together and that's but became now
it's the power that's why Godfather -
when Hyman Roth who was my olanski in
the old mm-hmm
he said we're gonna be bigger than you
were steel and they were they were doing
10 man a week Shh it was insane the
money yet and the buildings I mean the
buildings that here well you know he
owned 11 Wall Street I mean him and Joe
Kennedy during Prohibition they said
they made 50 manage Wow
that's a law but how I met all the
people are you same the waldorf-astoria
after the appellation crime can move
that whole raid mm-hmm they never did
that again so they had their lawyers say
where can we meet we gotta meet they all
took hotel rooms in that hotel I was
busy that casually bump into you every
mob film I met every guy and I was
always the kid always clean and he gave
me money he's gotta clean up that outfit
ice whatever you want me to do he'd give
me like $300 go buy clothes I'd buy
enough and give him 200 back I don't
know if he was testing me
I never abused I was rhythm oh then he
said in 1959 so where you start going to
Vegas for me it's okay whatever you want
me to do I always went by TWA
I didn't know they had how
use and I will use them anyway that's
another completely different angle my
story but no you were asking all the
time
you were around them all the time all
the time all the time only is the kid
people say what's that name is the kid
the way being left I know his name
well you never actually went in and
joined them up no never never
they added Sicily so hands are off that
kid a lot of people he'll I mean I got
so close to the people of Chicago Tony
Accardo I love Tony Accardo we made a
lot of a lot of business death and I'm
still friends I'm going to Chicago all
the time now did you ever hear a guy
called Frank Nitti no he was with with
Capone Frank Nitti was big legend well
you know too young his son Nick Nettie
and I were partners for years
mhm we would do a lot of laundering of
money through the Vatican which hundreds
of my men money and you can't even
believe on much money now his son John
Nettie is with me now his son it's so
crazy with three generations and Nittis
but in my book
this picture was nobody has his pictures
of Tony Accardo Nick Nettie and I at the
trivia film before going to Vatican
nobody that's these figs that's so
insane because you say oh this is so
far-fetched and then there's a
photograph and then there's our there
this is public that's it how do you get
this vote aggressive crazy and that's
before everybody has a camera there and
they follow now I've been blessed I mean
it's so crazy
there's a lot of stories about me of
people I killed and all that there's
always self-defense so how did you get
connected with Marilyn Monroe where did
that connection take place well that's
funny as the years progressed it was
like 15 and I got caught a couple of
times on the street I could do my
collections and a truant officer came up
to me was like May of that year
and he says come over here yes sir
is why should school at school I don't
go to school I maybe like 10 grand in my
pocket from clicking everything and I've
said he might not know this guy clicks
his money I how am I gonna tell Frank so
I'm being very polite he said well
you've got to go to school okay so he
saw he's writing me a ticket
he's what your mother follows men
and about the address 1 to 1 Mulberry
Street did you give this to your parents
if they don't turn the sin within the
next 10 days we're gonna come left you
know butcher juvie
that's juvie Wentz juvie juvenile home I
said ok so now I'm going to to choice I
dropped the money off the Windham when I
go to church that's why go because they
let me in me right Joe DiMaggio's at the
ball everybody's there Jackie Gleason
Jackie Gleason used to film at CBS
student right now we ever oh this guy a
Colbert show mm-hmm everybody's been
there and I used to go over there I'm
everybody knew me so I used to see
Gleason all the time and he was fun I
mean I had fun where all these guys
synoptic they used to drink martinis
like to look like me after all day so I
go there and it comes Costello
he sounds everything you look a little
down I said I swear that guy gave me a
ticket he looked at the ticket at 11:00
he's just think if you were ticket he's
your makeup walk one day they met him I
said no he said let me straighten it
eyes you couldn't straighten I said I
knew what she said so the next day when
I go to meet him all the time you see me
I just enrolled you in the school I saw
the water go to school just don't worry
about it you're gonna go to Willford
Academy it's on top of Lindy's right on
Broadway between 52nd and 53rd Street
you should go there and just check in
it's doing it's all covered so I go yeah
check in I had a meeting o'clock in one
I didn't have to start anything with him
until you have to know so the girl shows
me know what I liked about it was all
[ __ ] broads of it so I got my little
schmuck you know I think and they teach
rather scrubby and all that I didn't
give a [ __ ] about any of that
Wally's bronze I said this is like a
candy stuff for me to get it and I had
all the money in the world I'm making
dates cuz I'm gonna cooperate any time I
want
I just told L carmine I took them every
day they couldn't even drink that soda
they give me give me booze they didn't
care but I was dating these people
things of coppa seeing Sinatra I have it
made and then I got close to the lady
says you know you don't have to come
here every day I smile just come for a
couple of hours take it
cuz and I did that and then walks and
Claire
it was a colorist for L'Oreal us one of
those become his and Kenneth and Kenneth
he may know the name now became Jackie
O's hairdresser and she opened a shop
called Kenneth's in New York but they
were working at Lille - a on 56th Street
and Park Avenue which every society bird
in the world so they came up they were
looking for shampoo boys and me I'm a
clean freak like Paula type beef like
that is a mine in my shirt my uniforms I
do a my oh [ __ ] never touch my clothes I
mom I always starts so she like these
two Guardians came in they saw me and
they finger all this guy this piece of
candy and they said you come with us I
said whatever they say buddy and the
good news why I wanted to go because
it's the last hundred hours would that
count I can work and get paid in tips
and the last hundred hours goes to me
graduated they didn't know I think you I
didn't want to graduate soon as I was
December 12 came I'm sixteen see you
later with this infinite do and all that
as you would be the fourth hinder harem
Chapel you'd stand at attention the
stairs was a hot she was a haberdasher
one of the most famous Lily - hmm the
second floor was the salon so I'd stand
there and then they'd call me they'd
give me a card say go to room 4 never
give you the lady saying what she led to
rinse there's they taught you even their
procedure doll that I go into the
shampoo basin it's a little room private
it's Marilyn Monroe now I just finished
watching Mount Monroe at the New York
pamorah because when it was cold at
night and I was in at the bakery I go to
the movie theater well the 24 hours a
day and I had everybody knew me they
gave me free popcorn I'm watching my own
Monroe and some like it hot
I must have masturbated 15 times
understood it
we all wore dog food why not she was on
the cover of the first Playboy magazine
I know that she was she was she was
amazing so now that's about Monroe
I pulled the drape I don't know how long
I was looking at her but she said is
this someone any I said excuse me of
ladies and I had to go through the
procedures they you know about the
touching there the water on her wrist is
that the right temperature and she's
laying there like spread-eagle what I
hadn't shown that had baby you know yeah
we all know and she had this the smock
on but a legs I wound up saving myself I
can't believe this
so now I stopped massaging a hair and
she's moaning and she's more now my
mind's going crazy I get an erection I
must be pokin or Amelia because she's
there my three-piece sets on my shoulder
that she started requesting me then like
Christmas comes Costello says to me this
weekend don't make any plans I said why
he's we're gonna put my own Monroe in
the world off you know she is yeah I
know I'm downstairs with him I'm been in
the building they hid her out here for a
year look if you know that Marilyn
Monroe came here for one year in New
York when she was having problems with
Darryl zanuck and all the list everybody
was abusing her so she came in and they
loved her and I went yeah like he told
me to go I was there I brought my how
stupid I was I brought my little shampoo
kid I just gonna watch it so obvious she
comes out with this robe on I mean she
was gorgeous I mean today's world she'd
be voluptuous so we're talking have a
son waiting for the same when we're
gonna wash it yeah because I saw a robot
it's victory kind of you know which
throw it out and I didn't know what else
was but he just said they wouldn't but I
didn't know she wasn't going to win so
then she ordered room service I never
know what room service was I'm in this
room do you understand I'm 16
you are 16 years old 16 just 16 actually
this would maybe like January your blood
is sponsored by cialis at that time on
your legs I'll be a bleed bike you know
a Viagra but that's what got to Slade II
crazy cuz now she said you haven't
you like champagne ice I never had
champagne nicely thinking me little
drinks
seven and seven at the Copa when I was
you know but now she's got room service
and I'm here I am but sitting there I'm
said what's up my friends can't let you
see me look at this I got on the road
it's true she said let's go take a bath
I said you want me to take a bath right
it's just yeah come on
so she gets to the drop and she just
drops her a rope it walks like another
ten feet gets to the top she got the
bottle champagne two glasses women so I
go yeah I couldn't get my pants now my
dick was so big it's like everyone gonna
get over this thing and she's so much
attraction she said like yeah and I go
like you need it I said at the end to
the top I was gonna take anything for
granted but there was no way I had
nothing to light it with so I'm sitting
in the tub talking about everything in
the world I don't where to insult the
lady and she starts playing with me we
drinking champagne long story short I
left Monday morning to go to see him
downstairs and he's looking at me he
says you didn't want to ask he said two
gentlemen you've been here all this wine
since you told me to stay
we could have went home and slept that
was the weekend that's the weekend a
minute
that's that maybe the weekend of 99.9%
of sixteen-year-old boys in the world
that's like a fantasy right I could you
know I couldn't even tell anybody the
only person I ever told about that and
it came out later got too much respect
for women to begin with spin forward I'm
wit Marlon Brando and we're talking
whatever every night now him and I he
loves me you Ian stay where we all
stayed I had this apartment I stood at
the Park Lane because I wanted the
collabro coming out every morning with
paparazzi obviously that a bigger room
here but I want the media so I used to
go to the ELA zai hotel that's where he
was staying
he liked the monkey bar it's the live
and which they have all night long this
guy is nuts because we had cool you
never we different call times 2 o'clock
3 o'clock whatever and we're talking
about my own woman oh he loved him
a big affair I don't know we shed the
fair with everybody especially when she
was going to Stella Adler here a great
thespian teacher but he says to me too
bad you were never at Marilyn Monroe and
I looked at me said what was that look I
said I don't know
he's your Marilyn I said yeah I mean
being you're talking about I'll talk to
you about it I was with him this is I
think you're lying it's okay you should
tell me something that nobody would know
about well it's okay over her right leg
right and bright in this cleavage she
has a scar
he says you [ __ ] your with him and I
bonded up with that he's so crazy but I
was told to go to count Eva three or
four years later they commissioned
Marilyn to go to him and I don't know
what's going on I found out later said
to get everybody obviously John F
Kennedy I was hanging out with Senator
John F Kennedy for years
when he came to the Sands Hotel I
watched him do lines of cocaine offered
Juliet Prowse his stomach he never saw a
lady with a shaved [ __ ] that was big
thing enjoy your browser Ava God every
night that were in that pool I mean Ava
Gardner did everybody guys girls monkeys
anything she gives she was nuts
so when I was just always allowed to be
anywhere I wanted to beat up that was
Jack and trotta's building they built us
on the property to Sands Hotel as old
swimming pool you know waltz around how
is he how is that was hell is Jack Jack
was a great guy I met him here earlier
then they shipped him down the Vegas
when they opened the Copa room mmm and
that's when Jules Modell to ran this for
a while but comma and always ran that
but Jack was a great guy great guy
easygoing bond oh no Hardy guy and he
and see that what I can't hey I wasn't
realizing what they were doing that time
they were equalizing the syndicate with
juice they'd want to put Italians in
those deal
semen and again I don't know I never
segregated myself of being a gangster if
I'm Italian but they were that smart
that's why Costello called himself
Costello he wanted to be Irish he never
used his name
because when he took over Tammany Hall a
nice Irish guy you don't know what he
was a big guy but you know but that's
what they were doing man they
interesting they had more Jewish beards
we'd call them to run stuff and that was
Maya Mira's a genius why engage every
remote dateless no but I did sit down
with Oscar Goodman oh I love uh you know
Oscar you know he has stories and a half
ask him who controlled the mob business
Malhotra Tony Spilotro yeah Oscar
Goodman right to this day okay
you told you tell Oscar you talk to me
I'm gonna ask her just hired me for
April 16th to degree your mob museum
about my book it's the 50th anniversary
- Godfather real book I'm going there I
love Oscar Oscar and I go win another
entertaining guy I saw and a character I
shot two movies in Vegas he had to be in
each one he had to be here he played the
mayor of Vegas when I had an Ed McMahon
McMahon and McMahon was the governor in
my movie and he was he made himself I
love him he was a casino he was in
casinos and he was totally yeah I was
saying with Oscar Goodman is he had a
lot of things to say about the Lansky
and the influence he had in Vegas oh my
god and what he did through moe oh yeah
he dissed daily choices man that's that
that's exactly it that the amount of
influence he had to create Vegas into
what it is and they went through Bugsy
because a lot of people think it's Bugsy
it's Lansky who had the info used Bugsy
as the frontman yeah
and why bugs you got not I mean I know
they got a shot Bugsy
they were Beverly Hills marksmen shadows
through the window right through to your
eye that's where they got that thing in
The Godfather be modalys
I mean mo green mm-hmm that was pucks he
was supposed to date three million
dollars went south with all that
construction and everybody wanted to
know why and then when he opened he had
opens her a flop you doughnut they made
no money but the the foresight that they
had you see your took a wrong guy about
Vegas I know everything about Vegas we
had a club there was seven years old
before that Frank Costello and Joe
Kennedy on the Tropicana Hotel I had the
biggest nightclub in that way before my
club called Tiffany's I had Elvis
Presley open it for me Elvis Presley
when you pinch Sammy Davis jr. opened my
club Tiffany's in the Tropicana what
here was a Jesus I don't even know like
69 how was Elvis I love Ellen others not
stuck
what's this but how different was he
then everybody else was he unique in his
own way why he was just unique for who
he was I mean this guy was statue ash I
mean I mean I've seen him I had the
privilege of see because but my friends
Alex oofy and all of them and you know
Kirk Kerkorian of course welcome Curt
opened the hotel yeah but belong before
the M Jim he opened the international
opening week fourth of July weekend
first two weeks
Barbara Spicer second two weeks Elvis
Presley it's two shows a night no Kurt
Kurt and I were like this we get a money
I'm a with him he had the only show room
that's at 1,500 people everybody said
you're nuts
The Sands Hotel for the people 1,500
with a balcony
what happened with your falling-out with
Sinatra you had a so-so what when you're
about to do Godfather he called you
right don't call him 80 what was that
all about
oh he was nuts I mean I did so many
things with this guy I could tell you
stories about him forever but he calls
me up Dorothy calls me says the old man
wants to talk to you so I get on the
phone he said he got cast in the
godfathers yeah he says to me you're a
friend of mine - of course Frank he said
I don't want you to do the movie I said
what is I didn't really don't want you
to do it you can't do it okay
but I just spawned eight is I saw okay
no hung up I'm saying myself see [ __ ]
nuts so I waited a couple of days and I
played the game on him called Dorothy
assits could I talk to you a minute
get on the phone he started the
conversation I'm so happy we're turning
that movie down that's kanesha one
question you're a friend of mine right I
saw his dialog right back at him
yeah I second I actually questioned if I
asked you not to do here to eternity
would you have done it and he hung up on
me because he knew where I was going
[ __ ] you know it took me for three years
who cares for you he tried to eat them
one time could get stupid you know he's
bad if you have a temper bad drunk
temper okay
she's one of those kind of guys hold me
back hold me back in there's nobody hold
him and he's gonna get his ass kicked
I'm in the gallery in bar one night and
he's drunk like 3 o'clock in the morning
and I told me something that I could pay
attention to move so yeah I mean I don't
have to pay attention nobody I respect
everybody but don't call me a kid you
all walk ain't a [ __ ] cab so I go on
and he says you know when I tell you to
come here
I said scuse me as you can't talk to me
that was he looks at jelly
I put Julian a graver two minutes so he
raised his hand like he's gonna smack me
I grabbed his a little skinny young guys
let me tell yourself this is a warning
next time you raise your hand I'm gonna
rip off your arm and shove up your ass
and he looked at Chile's is Frank cuz
you can't I mean I'm a lovable person
I'm not a tough guy don't treat me like
I'm some bar rag cuz you're Frank
Sinatra I won't Eliot
that's one thing I would never let
anybody know that's why I've gotten some
trouble sometimes but I had enough
people to take care of though you had a
falling out with him again afterwards
though I had a lot of what was it what
happened with him in Marilyn Monroe
there's oh my god something about that
was in America gal Eva yeah when he had
me you were kind of a you know the whole
story was about to come out Marilyn was
gonna come on and talk about the
Kennedys what happened there what
happened there was that Kennedy's never
kept their end of the bargain when Joe
Kennedy went to Frank Costello and he
said well my son had become president I
need your help so they all got together
Cokie Civello with the Teamsters out in
Kansas see every mob I was traveling all
over the place and I loved it Bianca hmm
I bring this message that message this
message and obviously primaries coming
they still realized they don't have
enough votes they had all the culinary
vote all the international all showman
with the Anastasia Marcellus of New
Orleans you name every union Brotherhood
Teamsters everybody and the thing was he
becomes president we're gonna invade
Cuba and give you all your casinos back
was a win-win and everybody went for it
so now the guy becomes president John's
mistake was he made his brother Robert
attorney General Robert hated his father
his brothers when he stood for Robert
was the baby
he was mama's boy Joe Kenny I could tell
you stories budget
you would not believe now all those boys
had to have a [ __ ] in the house when
they were 16 he'd bring people in and
given [ __ ] make him bet he got to be
a man this game is crazy I heard some
stories about him always crazy he I know
nobody knew better than Costello because
they were partners during Prohibition
uh-huh so they were partners so what
happens he makes a maternity general no
invasion Cuba he said there's no
missiles they're loving this so they're
waiting they got nothing then I mean I
meant Marcello's house in the walls
because he knew their family things like
you're like good there's one thing about
me you invited me I show up see we're
gonna have this big barbecue I go they
read it's a backyard Oh US Marshals with
Bobby Kennedy and they were arresting
him they deport him and he told them
right then and there he says you're dead
it's oh now you're threatening you or
some Washington he threatened I'm
killing you your dad just like that they
took a lot of income and farmers
grandchildren and everybody that's what
kind of crazy he wasn't gone a week that
I was on another trip to Hollywood so
then what happened woman Rome when Rose
announcer commissioned to go to Catalina
Ken and so was Joe Kennedy Bobby and job
of course they weren't getting what they
wanted
so they were gonna set up my own Munroe
we're Bobby and John one more time
because they don't love [ __ ] her and
they were gonna film it like they did
with James remover they had jr. over in
that block over the years
so now cuz he was a crossdresser they
set up the party yep so they're gonna do
the same thing now mmm they had Marilyn
think I didn't like and I was with Frank
my pictures that pictures around that
pool with Sinatra laying there another
singer he was just up there plan and but
Sam Giancana was there everybody was
there and they were doing it Sam's crazy
I love Sam but they had house so strung
out that you know where she was because
she hated she's so in love with John
Johnson became president who's gonna
leave Jackie Mary off ah are you crazy
then she found with Bobby so they
thought and they had the room or rigna
with the sophistication we had today but
they had it John don't show doesn't show
yeah business couldn't come so at least
they said let's get Bob inna cuz he's
the one busting balls
let's get Bobby Bobby and her have an
conversation unbeknownst to everybody he
says [ __ ] you I'm going your brother you
and I'm going to public they didn't know
that she said that she calls Joe
DiMaggio in San Francisco
Joe come and get me I got to get out of
here cuz she will [ __ ] up Joe makes
the mistaken call Sinatra what's going
on there Frank
he's mining business don't come here in
Hong Kong
if Jay married at that time they were
divorced they were divorce but if Joe
came who knows she may still be alive or
next to home but no he didn't come Bobby
leaves everybody leaves she leaves in a
half two days later she's dead two days
later no overdose
she died of oxygen it's why I laugh
they're gonna exhume her body same I
mean I know so many people I know the
guy who does it they have a guy and
you're for hope me an organ and she had
pubic hair so they kept pumping oxygen
throughout for over here on the tushy
that's it had an aneurysm
Wow then they threw all this growth
which added up builds it or anyway how
certain are you of this story like how
I'll bet on all my kids are you crazy
you've been I would never say that I
know what I knew who they sent in this
guy works for everybody this guy worked
for everybody the government this it was
attacked it was thought he was a trained
trained doctor no they used him a couple
of times is it named public no he is so
respected with everybody everybody used
them CIA is Omar museum how about Great
Britain used once
Khrushchev used to this comes in the
world yes oh yeah he was the master
lives in Switzerland so popes that he
been didn't you and Frank still have a
relationship oh yeah at the end over
here we come back you obese we're just
gonna go he knows he's wrong
he thinks he's Caesar you know the
funniest story I'll tell you that the
last time I saw him was right down the
block
Jimmy West involved John Gotti he's at
Radio City Music Hall he's calling the
wall of Jonas on some of his people he
wanted 10 tickets from Sailaja John
Kennedy tickets he wants a New York he
didn't need so that's just as possible
nobody's calling we're in Jimmy Weston's
I really didn't want to go cuz I mean I
like those guys but I'm not
that guy that goes has dinner with them
the certain people I'll go with John was
out of control already he didn't like me
so I said Jojo why do I want to go Joe
was trying to make amends all the time I
made him I didn't want to be bothered
with so now we're sitting at the front
there was a little culvert the old Jimmy
westerns go down steps is old sofa so
we're sitting here John liked to sit
there go look at the bar and the birds
and all that this dumb stupid waiter
comes from behind John you're not gonna
believe this in the back Frank Sinatra
Don Rickles with their wives and I could
see John's whole demeanor change and
he's whispered to Joe watching his ear
next thing you know the waiter comes
with two bottles of Cristal from Sinatra
to John which is the biggest insult in
the world and that's while John drank
you know when he was out why is that the
biggest insult because you oh it's my
cause they want to buy me booze I don't
need your booze so he says to Joe take
those two boughs and go show him up his
ass now you can tell Joe Joe's very
loyal so Joe pick the bottles drag the
bull off and walk back there and I'm
sighs slide down to my seat I don't know
man so now picture this table Sinatra
Barbara Marx Don Rickles and his wife
so as we hear the story later Joe goes
back to it to two pounds puts them on
the table is what's that about
this is get up come on destroy the kids
so Celeste and he looks at Jilly Joe
without looking at Jilly like what
you're saying with the bottle crack some
guys down full bottle of Cristal you get
dead Joe it's 207 pounds done Don
Rickles pisses and shits his pants are
you gonna be serious he wouldn't show
it's like the ODE of the stitch what's
ridiculous so he comes back and people
are running out because first of all
they see what's going on
everybody's running outs of John sitting
there like Jose do that and then you
smell off of that they couldn't do it
everybody win I mean Don Rickles and
while you hear about that but he
literally did it right then in that I
mean Joe's a scary guy you ever see job
no look him up now Joe and I were
together since we're 14 I had was he
just as tough at 14 as he
you know later on he got worse I feel
bad because he always saw me and I know
him and he said I want to get it too
what you Tyson can do you know I'm not
doing anything believe me he's well and
then Maddie the horse owned all the
nightclubs up here the peppermint lounge
and all that and he knew he was being
robbed so in a conversation there was a
conversation envelopes had to go out to
people you didn't have those clubs and
they say what's the we're a little idea
well I don't know what's going on
so he wanted a non-italian because he
figured if you knew Italians they're
gonna know who the guy is so Joe Watts
was fresh Joe to German but big so he
put him on the door and in a week two
weekends three weekends Joey knew
everybody that was Robin so Maddie you
know many of us are mmm Maddy to us and
Manny and yelling he owned Umberto's
with Joe gallo got killed on his 40th
birthday
that's Mattie Ross God you guys okay
owned a lot of clubs and Whitman very
mobbed up he said you sure about this is
I'm so sure I want you to call your
doorman staff term eating and Umberto's
so you figured this guy cannabis he's
gonna tell us so he gets there he says
you know John we were all having
problems with money missing and I don't
want to point a finger at anybody you
know Joe to German and there won't look
like what's he doing in he said Joe gave
me an accounting and he says he has the
answers
and now they're all wiggling and it was
his nephew who led this group of
skimming the money from his own uncle
Maddie's sister Joe do you see the guy
yeah he's yeah that's him right there
was his nephew and then that he made the
mistake of calling Joe a liar is would
you just say you're a liar is you're
dead
Manny come on kill him cuz Joe kill you
right there he's done it you don't play
with job
you can never call me I'm an honorable
guy and this kids like he was waiting
for his uncle said you can't kill him
his uncle said you're gonna learn the
hard way
oh they didn't kill him though but they
he was banned from the family forever
Wow that's when it was what year is it
72 my god yeah seventies eighties yeah
so let's go seven days every one of
these I mean you you act it in a move
you were in a movie that if the greatest
movie of all time man you call it right
I mean it's just crazy what happened
with this that's my life how do I walk
at a Pablo Escobar's torture chamber
after three days I'm here yeah well then
how do I go see Sodom ooh saying how do
I got me how do I flee from your country
how do I leave your country honestly
it's about Johnny
if Headley these stories are true
they're crazy I told you earlier of 10%
of these resorts right well the funny is
they never all sure that's the funny I'm
just telling you I mean if somebody's
listening to this ain't come on John you
cannot tell me these are true but if I'm
telling you 50% are true this is crazy
what all the experiences you had but
what happened with Marlon Brando you
take the part you go he finds that you
playing Carlo then what happened
apparently only matter confrontation
because I was Francis Ford Coppola idea
we were up to patch his out of 19 he
took the back room there nobody's in the
back room during the day because that's
where they have the cigarette games that
night after midnight so the whole cast
is sitting around the table I've never
said we're gonna have a cold reading I
thought it'll turn the air-conditioning
on I don't know what they were doing and
I never read a script before first time
I saw the script I copied my loins from
the book and I made these things now I
have actual script I'm on a call sheet I
see a million an actor and I go with my
Chinese chick so far I got a Brioni suit
on and I'm waiting to see all these
actors sterling Hayden comes his hair
all messed up I mean even even Diane
Keaton she like combat boots on walls
everybody was scuzzy nobody was
addressed you know I remember the great
actors Fred Astaire you the way he
looked Cary Grant on vevo god these
people look like my god in a dress
better than them so now we're all
sitting around the table and Francis
says you know I want you
all introduce yourselves we know your
who you are but let's just break that
we're a family now
and I want the Italians to exaggerate
their mannerisms to teach the non
attacks like James Caan is Jewish Marlon
Brando's polish and he had all kinds of
food and now everybody just read the
script just read it but it got to you
about region line so we got out malambri
acting it's just really no yep just to
get familiar yeah yeah so Marlon Brando
then we all started laughing he was
gonna say I'm all preventable but we
didn't have to say not he got up and he
sat down then Pacino got up on that but
she don't play Michael and win around
little table came to me I'm Johnny Russo
playing call all and I'm dressed like
the a lawyer we go around we do the
first read-through we have a break on
the call sheet it says big lens do not
approach mr. Brando so nobody went near
him let me ask you at that time he's got
in Hollywood Marlon Brando's got a
definitely caught as an actor yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah I mean on
the world I'm calling the greatest of
all time yeah 30 yeah yeah don't talk to
him that's what set Gurkhas he's not
nuts I know everybody there cuz I go to
it so I'm at the bar talking this and
the other I come back in and he comes
over to me Marlon Brando and I'm saying
was this guy coming up early he says to
me you were a big TV actor I said no I
was like 26 at the time you got a big
movie coming out Chris O'Donnell is
really not on Broadway and everybody on
Broadway is who just study with mrs.
study what wait this he calls Frances oh
this is Francis Francis Ford Coppola
this is do you understand who this guy
is he's I can't even tell you who he is
he thought I was talking about you know
cuz he knew I got they can't find me
you're the director do anything else you
want this kid he's embedded but the
reasons I told you earlier that's right
I never broke down a script of what my
meaning is my pod people do he did it
for me he marries my daughter he
undermines my oldest son Sonny for the
barzinis he gets him killed it to toe
boots my son Michael tries to avenge his
death he has to leave this country my
whole family is destroyed like this guy
you better get another actor just like
that I'm saying myself
wait a minute I just had a big party I
told everybody's in this movie and
everybody was saying the same thing you
saying how you gonna be in this movie
you crazy not an act to get out of here
Johnny
this is that us get out of here I said
tell me I'm in the movie I have a big
party I didn't have a party on 5060
patches so now I said you know I longer
you're fired
I'm gonna then make my move so I don't
know protocol that I can't dismiss the
director even in the rehearsal he's the
director
mm-hmm so I said Frances go over there
been annoyed and he went now the whole
room is sailing laughs is this kid then
I did the next sacrilege I put my arm on
Brent though let's come over here with
me and I walked into the back cuz I
didn't want to embarrass the guy so
sooner we get out of here shot I had my
arm on him let me just tell you
something you [ __ ] us up for me you
hear what I'm telling you I will suck on
your heart right here who'd I tell you
to destroy my upper - it goes your
Marlon Brando he stepped back I didn't
know what he was gonna do he said that
was brilliant
he thought I was acting he came out of
the room he told me told friends
and then from there started she's with
me every day I couldn't get rid of them
every day cuz then he said now we're
talking yeah and everybody really get
pissed now took my Jimmy Carter's balls
like this look at this guy and the fact
that it's being shot instead 9 which is
where you grow up you know everybody
everybody would have to pee have to peel
with my wedding we're at my real
weddings the bane me no more ele on the
bandstand played for two different
weddings for me they wanted an Italian
wedding bill as I got him up come on how
you gonna get that
so wedding cake LaRosa's bakery make my
wedding cake I said what kind of cake is
all we want to sustain out with the
kosaka phony well how many tiers 6 I get
the King for you and I make money for
everybody
get the King Chatham 1,500 I get 500
they said what how are they gonna get it
done they couldn't get it done not
worship I mean insane what made his
style of acting like what like what did
he have a role like did he have a
routine right before he was doing
was there anything that to him was
random yeah random becomes don't forget
he's 3-4 hours of makeup yeah 3-4 hours
of makeup makeup yeah as that
transformations coming
the guy who were talking to when he
walked in I was in there a lot with dick
Smith my time the transformation is
resume and if it was a serious part
forget about it this guy was major I
mean he taught me everything the closing
scene he says you've never done this
before he says you're gonna be projected
in a single shot 20 feet of course is
you know you're gonna die and everybody
in the audience is gonna know you do
that you're gonna die
how are you gonna prove you know you
know or you don't know how you're gonna
batter you know don't know that you
don't know cuz you know what the
audience to know you're gonna die yeah
when he says get the hell on my face
right yeah I said what should I do is
I'm gonna give you some clothes it's
when he does this scenes with you first
of all whisper a lot of stuff you don't
like you want this to be between him and
you don't let the rest of the guys here
cuz you know they kill he's when he had
you a ticket looked down make sure
there's a ticket dead like you really
think you're gonna get out of it all
those little nuances he did that I got
not act wow he did but like even used to
when he hands you to drink don't get too
nervous to portrays it let him push it
up to you he did all that cuz I was so
afraid of Michael at that point so you
up until that when he walked in when I
got up and said Michael please you got
it overall I thought I could call him
too but at that point but he she said
one to show that transition and I'm the
people you know I got recognized in the
con Film Festival as most promising
newcomer they thought this well that was
grateful for quits I mean it's two
scenes that's crazy it's not just like
it's like one oh yeah
the other scene is which scene the scene
is where Sonny comes after you right
there was a baseball god yeah that's a
sick sense of calm cover yeah and he he
actually hits you with the bat by the
way I got hit me on the battery you guys
had issues like him a lot issues he
almost got me killed
he got me killed about the third third
weekends and throw two ribs of yours
well that was good crawling uh that was
still in that scene yeah he chipped my
elbow broke two ribs hit me with the bat
there was no bat when we rehearsed it
two days in a row he came up with that
improvising when he comes out of con
throws the bat and he hit me right in
the head
I mean but then thank God we're behind
the car but he thought I'd never get up
no he's over at that guy right Jimmy
Caan is so jealous I mean it's over now
but have you guys reconnected those day
I don't know I've never talked to you'd
never talk to him I'm not that guy he
always got me literally killed literally
with Junya come my bazooka who took over
the coal my family no jr. ye he set me
up and thank God I was with Tommy
Bilotti and Busey DeCicco if I wasn't
with those two guys I don't think they
were to kill me but I wasn't going on
the set Monday what was Pacino like she
knows gray Pacino when we met Pacino he
was just such a humble guy really well
he was a true actor mom and Pacino was
young and wanted to do this magic plane
Michael acquits career when no Pacino's
and I still love Pacino you know he's
got a lot of problems now oh I did any
given Sunday you know that mmm that's
what a white movies
you weren't super mario brothers as well
I think I did Seabiscuit yeah we only
got one Oscar nomination don't we give
more Seabiscuit why Jeff Bridges and
Tobey Maguire were awfully good of em I
thought it was a great movie
yeah I thought it was a great moment
here I mean I nicknamed one of our sales
guys Seabiscuit really I use I said
listen your nickname is Seabiscuit
moving for every time he calls me what
my phone would say Seabiscuit after the
movie came out so Pacino stop did he
have a routine or would he just
immediately bone he was in it right away
was there like there
I actually was invited one afternoon
where those three houses that were on
the compound
they took them where they were our
dressing rooms I didn't have trailers up
there there that was the confines up
there was so small so our base camp was
those houses everybody else was down in
the community college and they'd bust
them off but I used to watch these guys
do improv improvisation and get into
characters I mean I saw Al Pacino which
I couldn't even to today and there was
Jimmy call in the room Robert Duvall
these are all thespians yeah I mean this
is a legend a legend they would compete
against each other
Al Pacino did an improvisation of a
one-legged man cured up his ball playing
golf
and no ball no club put the tea in the
ground balancing himself one leg and put
the ball on it then go back for the
swing and it full get up again I mean
you I mean for a while that you thought
he had one leg you put the two legs
together come together but that's what
came that balancing who's in the room
when he's doing that all of you only
only actors are allowed in there and
everyone's seen him do this and then
they try to beat dance and do oh he's a
challenge had it was an accident it was
it an exercise Wow I mean who shocked
everybody was there anybody that was
like cuz Pacino you're expecting him
Casal John Casal a brilliant actor what
did he do just the things they did you
know they they'd read books it was no
books they challenge each other then
they would come a part of it they were
all do yeah totally improvisation it's
great to see that it was a great lesson
for me what it what has that movie done
to your life I don't think I have a life
I don't know what I mean I thought you
and that's a great question because
sitting here now 50 years 50 years is
crazy what I have amassed I mean I'm a
businessman I own not old I don't say
that cos government I represent all the
ip's I'm the ambassador ambassador the
quarterly old brands
Genco olive oil the company that I
represent haunted with Greco brothers in
Chicago they do six big in a year in
saying food groceries without us we're
about to go to 18,000 grocery stores
it's the biggest launch ever because
it's the Godfather it's new product
random but one of the oldest brains in
the world
listen everybody knows this brain Iran
we would watch God there translated in
Farsi I mean got it brother was like
required the watching you know you had
to watch so funny you just said that
Mike my two grandsons live in Italy and
my mom my one grandson sneaks close to
me yeah I don't have a good relationship
but a lot of my kids and he says to me
poppy
how many languages you speak we're
talking about he's I turned the
television
Chinese you're talking Farsi kiddo no
he's 8 years old what does he know he
thinks I'm a genius right
but think about this guy speaks 20
languages yeah because we watched
godfather translated apart have you
probably seen it to see what it looks
like I liked looking at that those kind
of things yeah last last story last
story I've interviewed Jim Jenkins Jim
Jenkins was the guide that was one to
four guys in the autopsy room that held
JFK's brain in his hands I interviewed
Clint Hill who was a Secret Service
agent for Jackie Kennedy was Secret
Service agent think for like five
presidents and he was the first guy that
jumped on the car when Dealey Plaza
later so you know Clint Ellis and a
bunch of other guys that have to do with
JFK what's your version the story two
days prior let me do that I went to New
Orleans
and I've run an envelope down which I
brownie envelopes here we go and I go
into to call us his restaurant and I
just came from New York and I ran into
the bathroom he says somebody in there
so a few minutes later a guy comes out I
gonna be I go and he just put down a big
plate if they knew I like pasta bowl go
away he'll dump they've unbelievable and
I sit down he says don't get comfortable
that's what do you mean he's got to go
back you got something for me I gave him
the elbow I just want to get rid of em
all up to begin with I said to mr. C
wants to know he's just telling this
it's all so he told me go back to New
York right go take a shower upstairs
come down and gonna meet him at 11
o'clock commit is what what's what did
he say he says it's on okay he slides
the manila envelope over to me he's this
$15,000 in cash and then there's
Merchant Marine papers and you're
leaving in there this week on the
independence it's okay is where you
going is you going on the ship this is
essentially gonna know when you land in
Barcelona come off the ship command I'll
meet you at the pier they'll have a card
name on it it's okay I said well he says
they'll tell you that then one that's I
did this so many times you know cuz I
didn't want to know he didn't want me to
know thank God he didn't want me to know
so now I go get all my clothes if it
eight thousand cash for spending money
oh and he said you're gonna go to go to
Layton's I set you up at Layton's we
weren't wearing Boronia he says go
Layton's get some closure be at the
captain's table every night
captain Bennington's to captain the ship
okay so I get on board and I'm going to
have to go had crude that care to go to
where the crew was and they said no sir
you have to go over your passenger ID
Gucci luggage it the reason he got me on
the ship as a hand dresser she has a
Merchant Marine there's no passports
there's nothing he didn't want anybody
know where I was going that's how much
she protected me Wow
I was gone 22 months I leave we're going
under the Verrazano Bridge I can
remember like yesterday on the
loudspeaker they said President Kennedy
has just been shot and he was dead I'm
getting chills even repeating it I said
oh my god cuz I just spent so much time
with John F Kennedy I went to do your
normal I was with Senator John Kennedy
watching a baby sitting for years while
they were grooming this guy that wasn't
enough now that night in the dining that
we could I mean could then now a later
on hours later they mentioned he's dead
and then I saw this is insane because I
was with I brought envelopes I went to
Texas when they convinced Lyndon Baines
Johnson to join the ticket
even though he had all these votes they
knew they needed Texas and Lyndon Baines
Johnson him like up kid I need you
couldn't stand the family but they he
knew they said to him before his terms
out you'll be President who told him
that I can't tell you tell him that
that's why I came along for the ride
that's why he brought him to the knoll
he was the only guy to brought him there
nobody brought that out yet and there
was three shooters that's why those guys
when they saw him they knew he wasn't
shot by Oswald and guess what happened
to me now we go next morning I get up on
a telex newspaper the guy that was in
the bathroom who you Harvey Oswald
Marcelo's hired him they wanted their
own hitters they needed trust anybody
three hitters the guy in the suit aren t
that someone's gonna get him the guy in
the sewer was the dead bullet that was
the boat that they can't figure out how
it made left's and rights
a good friend of mine too and what they
did to him they found him in a barrel
you know 73 people died since the
Kennedy assassination they took out 73
people calmly though he's gonna tell you
that [ __ ]
that's why then they did what they did
you know but Bobby sitting in the front
seat when that happened governor yeah
and he knew what's gonna happen we don't
know so do you come at LBJ you don't
know you just know what you heard that's
all that's all I ever do okay and not
even know that and you don't even know
that it's only hearsay
got it yeah you know it's everybody's
curious Manning you you would wonder you
would think like after all these years
you know a guy like that when all these
things coming out someone's gonna come
out and tell the truth on what took
place
someone with uh well there's a lot in my
book I'll tell you that yeah I mean I've
had even when you know when we when they
was um I was devastated because I really
liked the guy and not nor do I ever want
to say I was part of a conspiracy but
indirectly how I do was bring um boats
like her was dead and I was questioned
by everybody believe me and I waited 22
months I came back after 22 months I was
gone you were in Italy I started in
Spain the guy who picked me up we took
our time and I realized why and then I
finally got to Sicily and I stay we're
very close friend of mine who just
recently passed on and that was it what
a life you live all these stories I said
Davis they would say them nice and
Costello would tell who go go go go for
was the boss unless Lee says you want to
keep this guy happy to skip runs you get
his own food get him women you Grace
Kelly anything with Grace Kelly ER and
all I can
yep it's funny they did a story on me a
couple yeah a couple of months ago why I
didn't talk about Grace Kelly and I said
you know we're talking about Grace
Kelly's like talking about the Blessed
Mother I know Grace Kelly when she was
staying here on 63rd Street and
Lexington Avenue Barbara's not hotel a
family from Philadelphia sent to you for
finishing schools Costello would give me
an envelope to go to the floor monitor
after nine o'clock and this guy do we
used to call it flowers for the table
Branko gets me some flowers and I'd give
the guy the money and then one night it
was Grace Kelly when Audrey Hepburn and
two other socialites and I drop them at
the Copa or Latin Quarter they want to
be Woodrow Wilson they're all these guys
that's what it was all about and that's
one thing what Costello he took care of
everybody newspaper people police
department may is everywhere presidents
the amount of presidents they control
the ridiculous ridiculous how was the
race Kelly's personality more the
personalities and how amazing yeah
amazing lady and I was on it I were
talking I was at every every year
Princess Grace carriage horse my Monaco
yeah but what's interesting every year I
was at the Red Cross ball sitting with
Frank Sinatra everybody else Carrie
anybody was alive I was there E and
everybody said like who is this kid
last question Nixon mobbed up with Nixon
my oh my god yeah Nixon Nixon was I mean
there's so many that were but Nixon and
I kept thinking of people didn't figure
this out we all know Jimmy Hoffa while
he was in pre-op found God yeah and it's
gonna come out and this particular time
obvious on the FBI wiretap all over the
world they got me they I knew I was
screwed so but the good news indirectly
he got me out of that mess because I
just borrowed 72 million dollars of the
Teamsters and put my hotel in Vegas so
and I was borrowing a lot of money but
you don't have papist what do you need
to get it so he was gonna come out and
disclose Frank Fitzsimmons and all of
them or what they did with the pension
fund and the Brotherhood would vote him
in so they called Nixon they said I mean
yeah Nixon this she got a pardon Jimmy
Hoffa is what is important to me offer
any pardons certain killer
that's the story nobody ever tell you
that story he pardoned Jimmy Hoffa
Suzuki watch Jimmy officer certain
people can kill him who killed him Jimmy
Cooney Jimmy uh Jimmy James Cooney
something like that a name like that
he's a prison right now
yeah yeah it's apparently that's the
story I mean there's obviously a lot of
different stories when it comes out
tonight
well that's why I laugh all the time
when they saying oh the FBI has a tip
that they just buried in a farm they go
didn't dig up father
nothing comes up yeah I'll tell you what
Jimmy out there is how's that that Buick
they took the axles out and the motor
block out and they delivered it to
friends of us and they crushed it in
that car question thing and mob guys
were bidding on that pedestal it's a 4x4
piece of steel the friction heat and all
that there is no DNA there's nothing and
they say oh there's a couple of us that
know the story it's Wayne said oh he was
buried in the giant stadium means he's
buried they come up with all these
stories with Jimmy Hoffa is Jimmy Hoffa
is in a mob bosses basement game room
with a eight-foot piece of plate glass
over it and they put their feet up it's
only certain guys know that man that's
nuts
let's talk about this book Mario you
guys had joined us you just sitting here
like what we were talking about the now
last thank-yous and this is a novel this
is not true story based on a many
fictional stories here not just so Nick
Pileggi from Goodfellas Gianna Russo has
seen a lot done a lot and tells a lot
amazing Gay Talese generous as a true
character who has led the most colorful
life so what else can you tell us about
this book it's coming out what it's
coming on next come out March 12th year
March 12th
okay what else do we know that's gonna
be in this book I know you talked about
some stuff which shot what else is in
here the Vatican lot of stuff about
Hollywood a lot of ins and outs and
movie stars friends I've been with great
story about Josh and Gabor you got to
read
it's amazing I can't tell you what
happened in how he used his house that's
just so many great stories a lot of fun
things a lot of stories of how the
Godfather movie saved my life especially
Pablo Escobar I don't know his death cuz
you don't had a problem with two of his
guys went there because you know they
they believe in something here so when I
haven't had an incident my Columbia
State Street and I had to shoot this guy
after he spared this woman and he slit
my throat
and I just took him out only to find out
he was an underboss with Pablo Escobar
and they were just setting up a whole
new thing in Vegas
of drugs and his brother Lorenzen when
Delia was like this and he had to he
asked the Avengers brother's death they
believe in something here so I didn't
know anything about this Oscar Goodman
we were talking about earlier and then
different people at the time they got a
girl from UNLV to tell me about the son
Satya cuz I came home there was the
whole thing of my living room floor and
I live in secured compound and this is
on my rug and that my daughter pitcher
which Salome and is a chicken and all
this stuff
on my rug like steaks what circle and
she had to explain to me she said well
you are marked for death but they're
gonna avenge anybody and anything your
pets they'll kill you'll be the last to
go so I came to New York to meet Gotti
who's the only one I think I know he was
diving saved directly to him so again I
gotta say my good friend Joe watts
he's like this with John I said I gotta
talk to John they arranged it I come
here and I was wondering for the longest
time not a long time in a couple hours
while I was waiting to get on the plane
why is he doing this he figured out I
got that never come back he thought I'm
done with this guy finally so he
arranged for me to go to it I went I
went to Bogota because I figured let me
appeal to this guy I know my kids killed
and all this and friends of mine I had
nothing to do with this and I said if I
had a minute to tell him don't let him
kill me I don't care I don't want
nothing to happen to my kids and I went
and I met him in a church I felt good
about that and then when I want him you
know Pablo yeah Pablo and he was in a
church
the image of who I thought it was and he
was praying and the closer I got to my
smell flesh he was burning his
fingertips
I don't know mess with some kind of
penance he was burning his fingertips on
the candles as he was praying and as I'm
walking down the aisle to get to him
every time I walked 10 15 feet you hear
creaking of the pews and guys were
sitting up with guns so I thought I was
there alone there was about ten fifteen
guys in the church so all I remember is
going in to him and I said mr. Escobar I
gotta tell you and that's all I got out
I woke up chained to chairs my clothes
were stripped off of me the seat had no
bottom and there were body bags blood
all over I mean the stench in that room
and these guys were just having fun with
me then one day a man I'm sitting like
I'm done I don't know how many hours I
was there a guy neatly dressed standing
in front of me necessarily talked about
the Godfather and what it means to me he
says to me why don't you tell me you
will call him the Godfather and it was
Pablo Escobar you just take him upstairs
and clean them so I go he gave me some
pills that I was in pain they had a
shame and like a ball you know what
rubber on it and there be hitting me in
my groin area I mean my rectum and balls
I mean I couldn't even move for like I
walk like an old man at that time and he
very apologetic he gave me some pills
like if they took me to the room I
stayed there he says sleep I don't know
how long I slept next thing you know I'm
all dressed in one of them you know
those white beautiful colors
I mean having dinner with him and he
says to me I'm so sorry but my people
treated you like this I'm saying was a
you did you that's all not your people
and we talked for a long time and he
says tell me why did you come here I
said I had nothing to do with this you
are man or whoever he was because I
didn't want to directly say it's your
guy that's whoever you sent he breaks a
crystal bottle sticks it in this lady's
face I go to try to rectify it
I told him leave I did I said you know
Simon's too coming for you get out of
here
like if it was somebody and they're both
gonna have it I was I don't want to be
it Oh
the warden said the trial for two months
for you I said get out of here they said
no bond I said nobody with mom his mom
then I realized you know but I didn't
know he had the bottle yet in that zone
and that's when he went from my neck
yeah and I went back and that's why this
gin was hanging so now I have the green
light and I could play with it once I
know it's self-defense
that's all anybody I killed with
self-defense in fact the last judge I
was in front
this is mr. Russo I understand about all
the self-defense
he's been if you kill another person and
you don't open your shirt and there's a
big s on your chest
you're good [ __ ] crazy things with so if
you're enamored by all the stories he is
telling you Kate today in this interview
to sit down Gordon is book click on a
link below to order the book for
yourself and all these other stories
that he didn't share because we don't
have all the time you can read about it
when you order the book I heard the book
comes out with March 12 2012 March 12
the book comes out and then you also got
a podcast right yeah Hollywood Godfather
pod Hollywood Godfather podcast we'll
put that link below as well go subscribe
and listen to some of his podcast and
would that be so generous it's been a
pleasure sitting out here with you my
pleasure thank you